like to welcome you all to this talk on
field perspectives and violence in
mexico and venezuela sponsored by the
Saltzman Institute of Warren Peace
Studies it's my pleasure to present both
of the speakers I'm Austin long I'll be
moderating so the procedure will be
after they'll talk I think of fairly
briefly maybe half hour 45 minutes total
rest of the time for discussion in
question and answer please come up
because we are recording this please
come up to the microphone to ask your
your questions and we'll go from there
so first let me present to my immediate
left Jonathan callo her who's a senior
consultant and control risk crisis and
resilience practice I won't read his
full bio in part because he's a good
friend and I'm not going to I'm not
going to embarrass him with all the cool
stuff he's done but John is a former
Ranger platoon leader he has experience
in both Iraq and Afghanistan after
getting his master's degree at Tufts
University he went on to work for the
New York Police Department's
Intelligence Division and then he
subsequently went to control risks and
then further to the left is Dave Dinello
who's a senior fellow at the Foreign
Policy Research Institute in
Philadelphia dave is an expert on the
us-mexico border particularly based on
his long experience there he spent 18
months traveling back and forth on the
border from in 2007 and then in
2009-2010 so he's author of several
books on that he's also a former Marine
with experience in Iraq several tours
there where he received a Purple Heart
and commendation for valor and he's also
a very good friend so it's my great
pleasure to present them John will start
and then we'll move on to Dave and then
we'll move to question do whatever you
want
first off Austin and Columbia University
thank you very much for having us I'm
thrilled and honored to be here so this
is what I do on a weekly basis I work
with companies that are assessing their
vulnerabilities in their threats
globally today we're going to cater to
that to violence in Latin America but
please do feel free to ask the provoking
questions I know that you will I've sat
in several of Austin's classes in the
past and I've been incredibly impressed
with the student response and the
questions that you do ask so please feel
free to stop me and ask questions I'm
planning on speaking for about 10 or 15
minutes and running you through the
presentation that I work with clients
and let me just take one step back I
work for control risks and we were
security consulting company and what I'm
responsible for is the pre incident
kidnap and ransom training for
organizations for the Americas so North
America all the way down to Argentina
spent quite a bit of time in Latin
American and currently just by the very
fact that my clients need it I'm in
Mexico twice monthly will say so I don't
necessarily have the strongest academic
grasp of violence in Latin America my
formal education undergrad and then at
fletcher school at tufts was in South
Asian affairs really but what I do have
is a pretty solid understanding what is
morreion clients today and a granular
and anecdotal understanding of of the
issues that they are facing or they have
faced so with that side please how did I
find control risen I think it's a pretty
interesting story because I was sitting
in your in your shoes not that long ago
with one of my peers at
fletcher school and he owned one of the
larger shipping companies in venezuela
and did distance head while at fletcher
and we were in boston he showed up for
the start of semester and we were
talking saying you know Andres how're
things can I said I'm really troubled
you know my best friend was just
kidnapped and they'd been close friends
for 30 or 40 years so we haven't heard
from him and this was seven weeks after
he had been kidnapped so we finished our
masters 11 months later he came in New
York City and we had dinner down and
down in the village I said you know
Andres I'm just curious what happened to
her mind he said funny you should ask
nine days ago he was released after his
344 days in captivity I said that's
interesting said and what happened
during that time sitting you know I felt
so vulnerable during the incident I felt
had to do something so Andres flew from
Caracas out to Bogota met with then
defence minister now president Santos
and in that meeting was one of the US
where the u.s. is FBI legal attache and
also some of our consultants who were
managing this case and said I was really
impressed with the organization you
should check it out so I went through
the alumni network contacted my
predecessor who hired me on and really
put me in position today talk about
these things but what found me my job
was a violent incident in Latin America
a kidnapping in Caracas Venezuela that
lasted 344 days and you know by all
estimates the settlement was somewhere
in the vicinity of three to four million
dollars I'll take you through some of
our proprietary slides please ask the
questions we do have analysts that sit
in London that compile this information
for us I the only reason I'm showing it
we were not going to use any kind of
presentation but you know also an angry
both said it might be interesting to the
participants because you may not have
seen it but again please push me on this
and then some of these are just things
that I feel comfortable talking about if
this is the way we want to take the
discussion slide please awesome
it's like if you looked at kidnap for
ransom almost a decade ago you'd see
that two-thirds of all kidnappings were
happening in Latin America now it's
really a global problem it doesn't mean
that kidnap for ransom is decreasing
Latin America absolute terms it has
increased all this means is it has
become more of a global threat it's like
the cases that our consultants worked in
2010 and within control risks we have 15
response consultants there the
negotiator so if you're familiar with
the movie proof of life Russell Crowe
and Meg Ryan came to London to sit with
our folks back before that movie was
made to see how it plays out and much of
it was was accurate no obviously they
Hollywood took some liberties and
catering it to them to make it a highly
profitable movie but much of it was
accurate and as far as the global
marketplace we respond to about
somewhere between 70 and 75 percent of
all kidnappings globally they have some
kind of corporate flavor meaning the
corporation assumes liability and
responsibility for the individual that
was kidnapped now some of these times
they mail the family may say I
understand some employee you may want I
understand you employer may want to help
but I don't want that assistance that
does not factor into these cases we only
respond when the client needs it and
you'll see a tally dump in almost half
of our cases last year were in Latin
America and the 64 in Mexico I think is
really telling business is booming in
the 35-year history almost 2,000 cases
select I pulled these out and what I
think is interesting here the statistics
are less important than the trends and
if you look at Columbia which tops at
list from 2001 through 2007 you'd see
about ninety percent of those
kidnappings happen in that time frame
since 2008 onwards
you've almost seen it become
insignificant in parts of Columbia
mostly because the government has done a
fantastic job rooting it out and making
it a non-issue what we have seen is
elements from Colombia have gone
cross-border into panama and venezuela
and target folks they're bringing back
to that anecdote that i started off with
my friends with andres his friend
airmont they assess that the FARC was
tied to that kidnapping in Caracas and
mostly just because of the operational
understandings the first contact with
the family wasn't for seven or eight
weeks after the infrastructure that they
had to support them you know to hold him
for almost a year to feed him and by his
accounts care for him very well so we
have seen this rise cross-border for
mexico last count last year they're
guessing that ninety percent of all
kidnappings are not reported it's
underreported media media is getting
fatigued there and then the government
does not want to disclose that that it
is a problem they still want people to
come to Mexico so the 2500 is not
accurate Venezuela what we see largely
Express kidnapping has really become
significant business for folks in
Venezuela many times complicit with the
local police authorities and then Brazil
and I just being with our colleague here
before class and she had a close friend
that was kidnapped for three months in
Brazil we're seeing less of that
currently in Brazil kidnappings or a
couple days in duration but we are
seeing what we see is and call expressed
kidnappings where the holding them for
24 48 72 hours maxing out their their
debit cards and then sending them on
their way but what can we take this for
the last decade for the top ten globally
our Latin American countries and it's an
indicator that it is a significant issue
there slide
just where we went 2009-2010 side 93% of
kidnappings worldwide are locals and
mrs. there's a stark contrast between
what we're seeing global and I what
we're seeing a mexico in mexico fewer
than 2% of the hostages that are taken
our nationals and many of those times
many of the two percent it's a case of
mistaken identity it's a central
american it's a guatemalan that they're
believing is a mexican and they're pick
them up what we have seen is the cartels
are diversifying their portfolio not
only you know they're not looking at
drug and arms trafficking but they're
seeing that this is financially viable
method to continue to fund their
activity in Mexico so they're picking
people up they don't want to pick up
foreign nationals that essentially don't
want to bring undue pressure on
themselves durations known to us vast
majority the time it's less than a week
again we'll use Mexico is an example
last year for 2010 average duration was
about four days the maximum case that we
worked was 15 days now you might ask
about diego marty who is the one time
presidential candidate that was held for
the better part of seven months and
that's the outlier there's a 50 million
dollar demand but most of these
kidnappings that we're seeing are taking
less than a week in time slide victim
outcomes again contrast what we're
seeing globally with Mexico four percent
globally somewhere between nine and
eleven percent in Mexico a lot of those
are revenge kidnappings and so it's
cartel on cartel you killed you
kidnapped and killed my spouse daughter
cousin I'm going to do the same to you
slide slide had a video I'll show that
leader kidnapping extortion specific to
Mexico and again please feel free to ask
me about Latin America it is a problem
in Latin America but my expertise really
right now is on Mexico because that's
where I am constantly so I
1200 kidnappings reported in 2010 again
they're guessing that it was somewhere
tenfold of the hot slide the demands
give you a good snapshot of what what
we're seeing for requests both in 2009
and 2010 slide the victims high profile
case that I'm pretty familiar with is a
local government official on Monterey
that had her 20 year old college student
son that was kidnapped by aust enca
bleah Rosetta's cartel and held for
several days beaten up pretty badly
quite quite grisly as far as how they
brutalized his chest with a knife just
hacking them up he was able to escape
but what we are seeing is to insert or
assert political influence they are
kidnapping high-profile individuals in
Mexico slide durations in Mexico I
talked about this slide yes please go up
one
go up on
yeah yeah great question thank you in
for some of the cartels for them to make
a statement they're kidnapping and
killing either politicians police
officials or or family members thereof I
think the case in New Wave Laredo when
the you know the police chief that
stepped-up said you know I want to do a
lot for this for this town I'm willing
to do and then within a few days they
killed them it by no means is an outlier
we're seeing we're seeing several of
these cases and again it's not just the
kidnapping on that that wasn't a
kidnapping they straight up killed them
but some of these they're playing on the
emotions of the family and try to get
them to coalesce and say it I'll let you
operate here and I won't fight your
policy yeah
like the following special surprise
about resection
yeah yeah no no no great question um so
we're consultants we don't you know
there's there's no action arm of what we
do those those days are far behind me so
the way that it works is it as an
organization and i'll try to this will
be the CliffsNotes version but but
thanks for asking that most people don't
want to hear that's why I didn't address
it but so most what happens is client
calls and says I think I had an incident
we do some initial fact-finding say
answer these 15 questions and get back
to us once you have some more liable
intelligence once we say it's probable
or even reasonable to assume that an
individual is kidnapped we'll put them
on a plane from London in that interim
from you know from H hour until that
consultant gets there we'll have someone
like myself that will work with the
organization for the first 12 24 hours
however long it takes for Mexico
depending upon flight availability is
probably gonna take somewhere between 18
24 hours to get from London there so
work will work with them for the first
24 hours assisting them in whatever
capacity they really need as far as
working you know with any kind of media
problems that they may have if it's out
generally it's not and what we try to
say is don't put it in the media working
with family trying to tell them you know
you may not necessarily want to go to
the police now but we also into that
point specifically we will work with you
know a federal level police in Mexico
most of the time Mexico specific will
use and it varies by country we will
have a relationship with federal police
authorities that we do believe are not
corrupt there's over two thousand
independent police forces in Mexico
alone we don't know who to trust we've
had 64 cases there last year we know at
the federal level who we can who we can
co-opt and work through so we will do
that so it's highly scenario dependent
as far as what we do and how we r
bond and who we work with and then we'll
stay there we'll have two consultants
tasks that case for the duration of the
negotiation and they they go on and on
and off a row to schedule every 21 days
so 21 days it's actually they back off
about 48 hours so that they have that
proper transition so at the 19-day mark
the second consultant will come in and
relieve the first send him out and
they'll stay on that road is scheduled
for the duration thereof you know the
one very public case that has been
written about and we've been mentioned I
feel I can disclose was the Northrop
Grumman case it lasted five and a half
years and our consultants we had two
consultants that works that case four or
five and a half years it was the same
two gentlemen that managed that case
from our end did that answer your
question yeah sly please select
extortion trends the the extortion issue
in Mexico is becoming particularly
vexing from a practitioner standpoint
because it's so pervasive we're seeing
cartels that have and it's
understandably so they've done a good
job of scaring people into saying hey
for 150 thousand dollars I have no
problem paying them and sending them on
and sending them on their way otherwise
they're going to kill my entire family
the problem is they're not going on
their way they'll make 150 thousand
dollar extortion demand that will
quickly become a four hundred thousand
dollar extortion man that will quickly
become a million-dollar demand and it
will cause the business to shut down so
it's highly problematic for us and
really we're seeing it almost on a daily
basis and it's underreported because
many of them will just pay at first at
first black yet please pray
now yeah so we're never the negotiator
our role is to serve as the coach and
not the player and we're more effective
that way where we can take a step back
and look at things strategically see
where the company wants to go the
organization will pick someone that
negotiates and we call that person the
communicator and they are the voice of
the organization and it's going to be
someone that's not in a position of
power within the organization but a
couple layers remove where they say I
can't make decisions I can ask my boss
for the decision but I don't have the
authority to make a decision on my own
so that's how we work with them and we
never deviate from that is it always is
the negotiator always going to be a an
employee know sometimes and they go to
the family but what you want to do what
we try to do is funnel it so that they
know that there's only one client if it
goes through negotiation it's a very
good thing they're probably not going to
kill the the employee spouse whoever it
is because it means that they want money
they want to negotiate something most of
the time that they are killed it's a
kidnap for execution they're kidnapping
them they're never making contact and
they're killing the individual they
understand don't want any money i'm
going to kill this person so if it does
come to negotiation it's very positive
from our perspective it's like our
forecasts listen Mexico isn't
Afghanistan or Iraq and this is what we
do convey to our clients nor is Latin
America I've been over much a lot of
America and Latin America is not
Afghanistan or Iraq you can't operate
there but it does take some prior
planning and risk mitigation and
understanding of the potential impact to
do it well what we're seeing is most
organizations understand this in there
doing this it's like yes please
sure you're right case studies 2010 what
we saw dependence locals most at risk
somewhere two to three percent you know
three per cents airing on the on the
high side being quite conservative it's
really about less than two percent slide
case studies renault so what we're
seeing is common thugs in mexico are
saying that they're tied to these
cartels and it's so they can command top
dollar for the kidnap for the extortion
happened in Reynosa on the border
individual got picked up by what he
thought was a couple at five thirty in
the morning held for seven hours said
that he saw seven executions and then
they released him for the equivalent of
one hundred and twenty dollars his
cartels a multi-million dollar
organizations is it reasonable to expect
that they'd released someone for one
hundred twenty dollars in my mind it's
not I spoke about the Monterey case me
choke on that extortion threat of
somewhere along the lines of one hundred
eighty thousand dollar extortion demand
to stop their operations you know they
said you're in phase one hundred eighty
thousand dollars and I else you want you
to shut down operations here what they
want to do from from their perspective
what their said what family assessment
was is they employed a lot of the local
agricultural workers and what they
assessed and again this is what a client
assess said we think they want us to
shut down so that they can pull from our
pool of employees so they can recruit
it's interesting how reasonable is it I
don't know we weren't ever able to to
determine what happened they ended up
paying 180 thousand dollars and didn't
shut down the operation and they didn't
get reheat for for any additional money
so I guess to be determined on that one
slide please should I feel questions now
listen or turn over Dave and then note
the stereotype and then we'll do
new questions after thanks John slide up
to thanks thank you for having me I'm
David Dinello up from Philadelphia
senior fellow at the Foreign Policy
Research Institute I would say I'm an
expert in I have a background in the
Marine Corps but I'm an expert in the
us-mexico border international border
analysis and field research and to talk
more about field research and the way it
the way it relates to Latin America in
the Latin American context can we go to
the beginning of the presentation yep
this backup will just work there so let
me let me get a feel for where we are
raise your hand if you've traveled in
Latin America that's that's what I
expected now raise your hand if you've
been to Mexico City also usually kind of
the starting point obviously for
understanding Mexico and Mexico's
relationship with the United States
raise your hand if you've traveled on
the us-mexico border okay also expected
raise your hand if you've been to
Chihuahua city atomo CEO or Co but ago
that's also what I expected that's one
of the things that that has become
relevant in understanding the way that
not just us-mexico relations have
evolved but us Latin American relations
have evolved is understanding more about
the fault line between the United States
and Latin America's evolution over the
past probably 15 or 20 years which
really is northern Mexico next slide do
we have the facts slide up that that get
pulled in we missed it northern Mexico
northern Mexico facts other oh oh it
looks prettier thanks mutated sorry
about that it's now property of control
risks so
northern let me speak in greater detail
to the to the facts and what makes
northern Mexico distinctive northern
Mexico six states those six states come
up against the the United States on the
four states of the us-mexico border
eighty-five percent of all u.s. Mexico
trade either originates from northern
Mexico or flows through those ports of
entry so it's significantly economically
connected and very economically
important to the United States it
obviously now is the home of 55 to 65
sick roughly between 55 and 60 percent
of the drug-related violence that the
Mexico seeing and the drug-related
killings specifically eighty-seven
percent of Mexico's maquiladora
manufacturing twenty twenty-five percent
of Mexico's 11 million 111 million
residents that statistic has doubled
since NAFTA that's important to
understand because the degree of
connectivity that NAFTA created between
northern Mexico in the United States and
the robust growth that was generated in
northern Mexico is often of
underappreciated how many of you had
been two month away in anybody in in
South Texas south of its south of South
Texas about five hours from Houston
Monterrey and Houston the standard of
living is at one point was nearly
identical over the past year and a half
particularly it's come under siege and
that's important in terms of
understanding the geopolitics of
northern Mexico and the violence in
Latin America as a whole in our response
to it other thing that's important is
the US has a huge diplomatic presence in
in Mexico we have more consulates
embassies and and posts in Mexico than
any other country in the world it's tied
with China right now it's actually one
more than China and two or three more
than Canada but those are our three
largest trading partners which is why
we're so we're so connected there's
seven consulates specifically in those
six states in northern Mexico
next slide I have let's back up to the
geography slide so what I've got now is
is I've got four maps that will talk to
and that I'd like to use to frame our
question-and-answer session first let's
just take a look at Mexico in the
geography of it Mexico is so mountainous
that if it were flattened it would be
the size of Asia most people don't
appreciate the character of Mexico's
mountains and how that jagged terrain
defines the scope of Mexico particularly
in the north let's just take a look at
that kind of working our way from west
to east and we'll keep doing that as we
go through these slides so Baja
California obviously it's an isthmus and
you know mostly defined by its mountains
in its coasts and then as we move into
Sonora there's a huge expansive desert
broken up by the Sierra Madre Occidental
which stretch all the way down to Mexico
City three mountain ranges in Mexico
Sierra Madre Occidental Orientals and
Bill sewer in the south and then moving
into Chihuahua chuo actually has three
different geographic regions its
mountains steps at planes in desert that
West Texas tethered desert and
chihuahuan desert back before there was
a border of Iquitos and cowboys crossed
it routinely and they still do and
interestingly enough even after the
us-mexico border was defined the borders
most stable period does anybody know
when it was when the us-mexico border
was the most stable in in history in the
history of its existence from 1848 to
today it was actually from 1886 excuse
me 1876 until just before the perfidy
Alto ended and I know that there's a lot
of unpleasantries that occurred during
the port fiddy Alto to say the least but
one of the interesting things that
evolved from 1876 to just before 1910
was an agreement between the US and
Mexican government's where they could
patrol the border jointly and it Mexican
Morales routinely road with with Texas
Rangers and American soldiers and there
were a number of joint efforts that took
place that served to stabilize a lot of
the bay
the tree that had characterized the
border up until that time and and then
continued to in the wake of the Mexican
Revolution and then through the 50s and
60s and into the various iterations of
the border today we can talk in more
detail on that in the Q&A but it's it's
a very interesting period of time where
there was a strong degree of cooperation
between the United States and Mexico
continuing to move east let's go with
the next slide the population density as
the population of that northern Mexico
region is as we can see it pretty pretty
empty it starts to get a little bit
little bit more dense as we move east
one of the reasons behind that next
slide is the character of the Rio Grande
most people don't realize the Rio Grande
actually starts in Mexico it's most
strongly influenced by a river called
the the Rio conchos there are seven dams
on the Rio conchos where the headwaters
are in the chihuahua in this in western
Chihuahua in the in the Sierra Madre
Orientals and the flow of it without
those seven dams flows and surges right
just right around Big Bend National Park
where ojinaga and presidio are is where
the Rio Grande really picks up steam
north of that it's almost a different
River and when you when you travel the
border and you can see that and you see
that change that it takes where the
conchos flows in you almost want to call
that the northern Rio Grande and rename
the river entirely because there are two
dams north of that that where the Rio
Grande as we call it actually starts in
Colorado but from that point north you
can actually just walk across it anybody
been to El Paso you didn't you know
exactly what I'm talking about the Rio
Grande is there is it's basically a
creek and you can stroll stroll back and
forth that it will if there if there
wasn't a international border there but
this is important for understanding the
character of the economics in South
Texas and North northeastern Mexico
because that's a river delta and the
same qualities that exist
any River Delta the Nile Delta the
Mekong anywhere in the world exists at
the Rio Grande as well huge farming area
very fertile it's it's a large Basin
next slide and this will be my last one
and we'll talk to this a little bit more
so this is what the geopolitics of
northern Mexico in terms of how we
develop us-mexico relations and
us-mexico policy and how we address a
lot of the violence that's taking place
in in in Latin America in general and
Mexico in particular normally we focus
culturally on Mexico City let me take a
step back for a second and focus more
culturally and geographically
economically politically and and
demographically to some degree with each
of these three regions specifically in
Baja California nine out of every ten
people live within 50 kilometers of the
us-mexico border not and so the
character of Baja California is very
influenced by the economics between
Tijuana and and San Diego very very
influenced culturally by Mexico's
sensitivities towards the Baja Peninsula
the Baja Peninsula protects Mexico's
from a naval perspective that guards
Mexico's western flank they were most
aggressive the Mexican government was
most aggressive during negotiations that
ended the mexican-american war about
getting the Baja Peninsula back the
United States had occupied it during
during the mexican-american war and
there were a number of unhappy Marines
and sailors that were evicted from Baja
California and relocated to San Antone
excuse me to San Diego which was placed
under martial law until 1850 because
they had large tracts of land that they
had that they had seized and did not
want to give them back back to the the
Mexican government in Baja California so
Mexico City is very sensitive about
maintaining control and and not giving
giving that up to Alta California the
Sierra Madres is as as we mentioned very
defined by the mountains and very
defined by
by the character of cooperation with the
United States over time and
interestingly enough at a museum in in
edameh seal which is the capital of
Sonora the museum of the state history
museum spoke of a degree of animosity
towards Mexico City as though Mexico
City kind of sold them out during the
mexican-american war there were I don't
remember the exact number i want to say
maybe twenty or thirty thousand people
total that were forced to there was a
supply line that was cut off during
during the war of independence from
spain in 1821 from eighteen throughout
the 1820s and they were forced to flee
ranches and flee areas and that area was
not rebuilt during during the years
between mexican independence from spain
and the mexican-american war and there's
a belief at least expressed as expressed
by the the exhibits in the state history
museum that had mexico city invested
more time in in taking care of edimo CO
and Sonora and and the northern region
than they would have been able to defend
against the North Americanos and there
would have they would not have had their
terrain violated and and that may have
been more more machismo than actual
analysis but but it's there and they do
hold some degree of resentment towards
Mexico City the Rio Grande Basin is by
far the most interconnected region to
the United States the ties between
montalais and Houston the business
community a san antonio austin dallas
and it's so connected that the exhibit
in the museum of the no desde in in
monterey celebrates their tie to texas
as though texas was still part of
northeastern mexico and the actual
exhibits in the museum say that well you
know texas was so successful
economically throughout the 20th century
because well they were they were tied to
this economic revolution that began in
the 1880s in northeastern Mexico and so
that laid the
don't worry about that that's not that
big of a deal but really being part of
northeastern Mexico was is tremendous
it's also it's important to understand
the the sensitivity that mexico city has
also to the business community in
monterey it's multiplied as the
wealthiest it's it's the wealthiest city
in Mexico per capita so we might think
of it as if if New York were a third the
size of Washington DC in terms of the
political and economic relationship
between month clay and and the FA and
that's again a generalization but but
but a reasonably accurate one there is a
cultural distinction that's important to
identify between montalais and end the
FA and that is that month of a which is
the capital of what I've described as
the Rio Grande basin was was not a
native city it was entirely founded by
European so it's anand there was never a
pre-existing city or pre-existing colony
or pre-existing anything before espana
occupied the city and founded it it was
founded in 1538 so there's a very
significant cultural distinction between
the history of multiple a witch then
frames the perceptions and the cultural
connections between the united states
and specifically in South Texas and the
Rio Grande and and they FA which as we
all know has has a long and painful and
sordid history of any number of
iterations from but more specifically
the the tension between Montezuma and n
Cortez that is a that is a quick summary
a brief summary of of that that fault
line between the United States and and
Mexico I with that I'll sit down and I
know that our conversation our
discussion revolves around violence in
Latin America
violence in Mexico and obviously the
three of us all come from a perspective
of I think both of these gentlemen are
more much more active academically
credential than I am I'm just a guy who
likes to run around and look at things
and write about and I've done a little
bit of that in my time but with that
thank you thank you for your time and
great okay I'll say a couple of words
many of the trends that both John and
Dave mentioned are present in other
parts of Central and Latin America I'm
particularly thinking of the of the
cellphone extortion calls that John
mentioned from prisons it's a major
phenomenon in el salvador in other parts
of Central America I don't think it's
made quite as much inroad into latin
america but but i doubt that bull will
be very far behind so well we've talked
a lot about Mexico and specific I think
that these are sort of broader
phenomenon and we can talk about these
broader phenomenon if you want so with
that I'll open it up to questions if you
would come up to the mic since we are
recording it and we'll start there if
nobody has a question I'll think of some
excellent
thank you very much for coming very
interesting um my name is easily I'm an
alumni from Columbia University I'm
interested to hear your thoughts a
little bit as you know Obama's in Latin
American today he's an outside of our
thought which has one of the highest
murder rates a quarter of the citizens
have been victimized by crime so I'm
interested to hear a little bit about
your your thoughts on what is the role
of the US and international community in
particular and supporting the Central
American region in addressing the issues
of crime the modest and especially with
the u.s. having a regional base there in
those Salvador thank you I'll take a
crack out of you guys so I've been I've
been dissolved or a couple of times
lately most recently in December the
United States is is providing a lot of
support to Salvador as you mentioned
there's a regional base there but it
operates from there throughout Central
America with Salvador you know the u.s.
role goes back in a major way three
decades but it sort of petered out a
little bit in the 1990s and 2000s and
has recently gone up so the US has a
major USAID program to try and build up
local policing their FBI liaison so
they're doing a lot there other parts of
Central America the United States has
even dispatch Special Forces teams to
held up help build up border police
capacity in Guatemala so there's there's
a lot of effort to do things now Mexico
and probably Dave and John could speak
to this I think is a bit of a different
case Plan Colombia in Colombia was a bit
contentious but it was framed through
counter-narcotics lens and was happened
even though it was really a
counterinsurgency program but it was
still contentious I think Mexico will be
much more difficult simply because of
the the relationship it has the United
States to provide the kind of support
that is you know became routine with
Plan Colombia and is still pretty
routine in places like what to mali in
el salvador so maybe you guys could talk
to support to Mexico
I think well more to your question about
Central America there's there's some
interesting events taking place in in
Panama as well that it will be
interesting to see how that relates to
El Salvador and and some of the
initiatives that that Austin described
the you know the standard phrase in any
political circle now is capacity
building and obviously continuing to
that's that's a you know that's the
standard boilerplate answer to your
question which I think I think Austin
captured in more granular detail
capacity building in Central America I
think will be to make us to make a
generalization it's going to be easier
than capacity building in Mexico for a
lot of reasons which we can probably
expand on in the Q&A yeah I think some
people try to say that Mexico today is
Colombia 1985 and I don't think that you
can simplify it like that I do think
playing Columbia worked for a number of
different reasons and just you again
from my perspective the clients that I
work with don't have the faith in the
infrastructure of Mexico that I think
Colombians did in their police and
military forces and then even the
government that helped execute it
hi my name is Jennifer thaxted I'm a
student at ciba my question sort of
piggybacks on the last question but has
to do a little bit more specifically
with the role of the US military and I
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about possibilities for foreign
internal defense in Mexico and what it
should look like I know that the Mexican
Navy has been in the press of late as
being a real competent branch of the
Mexican military but should it look
should we be training their army should
be looking at police forces do you think
it's a good idea at all thank you I got
some thoughts yeah oh yeah I'll take a
little tickle lead on this one um you
know there's obviously how many folks
have read the wiki leaks disclosures
about about Mexico specifically anyone
not that I'll admit to so I mean there's
it's it's fairly hidden in plain sight
that there's that there's some activity
that's going on in in Mexico that that
the United States military's is is
involved in it you know at least that's
been been disclosed in wiki leaks and
that sort of thing my broadest concern
about this is categorically speaking
we've got overt and covert activities so
it seems like the direction that our
government has has gone has been in
partnership with the Mexican government
that there's been considerable interest
on both sides in maintaining covert
activity and in saying okay well we're
going to do capacity building we're
going to do you know foreign internal
defense and and these things the plan
colombia into plan mexico and we have
the merit initiative and we have all
this but once we get down to brass tacks
in terms of whether it's taking on a
high-value target or developing
intelligence or anything that that those
of you who have austins classes study
the tactics and operations of on a daily
basis that's what we're doing what we
don't have right now is an over legal
and diplomatic framework that that
governs and institutionalizes these
relationships so much of our activity
with the Mexican government is built
foundation
Leon personal relationships one of those
has been deteriorating for a while and
collapsed this past weekend as I'm sure
most of you are familiar in the news
with the the Mexican the u.s.
ambassadors to Mexico's resignation we
got to work on that we've got to work on
developing and continuing to strengthen
the overt process that we go through and
that requires going through you know
both houses of Congress both the Mexican
both the United States and and really
getting consent from the US and Mexican
people as to okay are we going to
establish zones along the us-mexico
border where we cooperate where we can
do interdicting activity are we going to
you know how are we going to
institutionalize and maintain a extended
period of cooperation that's going to
last decades rather than rather than
work ourselves out of a job as we did in
Plan Colombia oh no I mean I guess to
your second point and this is just I
think you were getting at it but the
professionalism of the Mexican army
there has to be the Marine Navy folks I
don't know if you wanted to comment on
that I know George racin who works with
him has said you know categorically that
the Navy Marine the Mexican Navy Marine
folks have done a much better job of
fighting internal corruption um and
working in partnership you know with the
the non corrupted police forces in
Mexico so I think you were making that
point and I'm just reiterating in and
confirming that I think that your
assessment is right and I agree the
other thing is you know I think they're
there may be a knee-jerk response that
that is a bit within the u.s. to
militarize these things and not that the
military can't be a good tool but so
much of the problem and I'm going to
sound like a little bit of a hippie is
is it the governance level you know it's
not the military force can't do certain
things but a lot of this is legal and
institutional so to take salvador again
as a relic of the Civil War until
relatively recently they had no wire
blah so it's awfully hard to make cases
against people making cell phone calls
from prisons when you can't legally
monitor phone conversations so I think a
lot of the problem aren't the
institutional things like that the other
bit and this is more speculative again
based on some of my time and Salvador so
in Salvador as they happen Mexico as
they did in Colombia they've started
deploying the Army again in an internal
security role and that was verboten
after the peace accord for a long time
they finally started doing that one
concern a lot of Salvadorans have is
that the army which is very well
respected now it's taken really 20 years
to get to that point but they've sort of
cleaned up human rights violations
professionalized all these great things
there's a real concern that in leaving
the barracks to go to the street the
corruption that has basically not
touched the military to date is going to
inevitably start seeping through the
military and I wonder a little bit if
that's not a story of the Navy and the
Marines who have been sort of on the
coast and hanging out and not as deeply
involved in this sort of day-to-day
street level stuff i mean yeah they
would do drug interdiction so there's
not that there was no chance for
corruption but i wonder if they've been
a little insulated from pressure in the
more they get used in these kind of
operations the more that's a risk I
don't know do you guys have any thoughts
on them other than I agree I did the
same you know Mexico has been wrestling
with that since december two thousand
six when they said okay we're we're
going to send the army in more they it
is a war how do you prevent the army
from being corrupted it's not a you know
it there's no universality to hi my name
is Nate Rawlings and I'm a student here
at ciba to my question is about pre
violent incident prevention other than
maintaining a strong security posture
have there been other techniques that
have improved successful intelligence
gathering or any other techniques to
prevent violent incidents before they
happen yeah great question um well yes
mine kick this one off as far as what
we're seeing from corporate America for
mitigating factors is there continuing
to run operations but when possible a
lot of organizations or corporations
rather
have moved any non-essential activities
back cross border back to Texas so many
of these corporations that do have
operations either along the border or
Monterey also have some kind of
operations in in Laredo in McAllen in
harlingen and they're they're pulling
non-essential personnel back out so what
they're seeing is yeah he might it may
be the man or woman is the local plant
manager for whatever company but do they
necessarily need to be on site all the
time no and they're going to be the
people that are better targeted is what
we're seeing so what they're saying is
unless you absolutely have to go to the
plant and rinoa and where Loretta
Monterey please stay on the US side so
that's one thing that that we that I've
seen organizations do the the flip side
of that unfortunately is that when you
pull the economic activity out of the
area then you have a large population of
unemployed men aged 15 to 40 who are
trying to feed their families whereas
right and that's that's exactly what's
happened in in many of these these areas
where very good for the client or good
for the company bad for the area
mr. Donnell which was the only target
diet and was able to attend you
suggested that plan colombia and india i
think mr. long as well has been a
glaring success but how would you be so
optimistic about something that has been
going on for i think we are 12 years and
sure the ddddd coca leaves crop has been
substantially reduced but this is still
in very high numbers i don't remember
the exact number is for me the magical
number is 100 but i don't remember if it
is 100 tons or 100,000 pounds or kilos
but in any number in that in that
territory is still a very substantial so
III might quote and i know that he's not
very popular in the indie in the
military of former military of cops
community Julian and sange there is an
interview of him in samana which is a
colombian weekly magazine in this week
in which he says that it's been a big
success but for American contractors and
it brings I mean the academic that I am
NOT but there was a guy at one and well
Prize in Economics in the 80s mid 80s
called Buchannon not pad in of course
that actually he's more of a political
scientist and he one of his main
contributions to Social Sciences about
the power of bureaucracies to affect
policy decisions and in this case is not
just bureaucracies all the bureaucracies
that are involved in the so-called or in
the war on drugs are all those acronyms
donations but also the the the business
interests that call for keeping the war
that has Amina and I lastly I want to
quote more or less Nixon's remarking in
1971 and by which he praises the success
of the recently initiated war on drugs
and according to him marijuana crop in
Mexico which was a big problem at that
time had already been solve it and there
was a big success in the war on drugs
according to to Richard Nixon 40 years
ago let me just first the distinction
between I didn't say Plan Colombia was a
success what I said was the strategic
approach will be I think have to be
vastly different than the United States
took with Plan Colombia and is you know
frankly continuing to to use and and
that has been institutionalized in our
relationship with Colombia more to your
point about the war on drugs and the you
know never-ending or perpetual state of
it the Nixon Commission actually had
wrecked the Commission every member of
the Commission recommended that
marijuana be legalized and Richard Nixon
personally overturned that as part of
the when he did the war on drugs and/or
when he legislated the war on drugs
let's do just a quick hand so raise your
hand if you think Marilyn marijuana
should be legalized raise your hand for
cocaine meth heroin I'll just keep my
libertarian handed right there we go so
it's not but the point there's there's a
pretty broad societal cuz I do this
routinely whenever we whenever we had
this conversation because most people
think that a former military guy would
be extremely militant against you know
legalizing and frankly that that's
that's not my position at all I think
it's I think it's important that the law
is that the United States has and that
we are prosecuting reflect the will of
the people in my experience in
observation there does not seem to be a
broad societal consensus on marijuana
being an illegal narcotic that that just
doesn't appear to exist the politician
who has most vocally addressed this
issue by the ways former Marine Senator
Jim Webb who has recommended in a number
of public forums that the United States
accomplished a fairly robust reform of
its justice system that includes taking
a real hard look at decriminalizing
marijuana and he's been the strongest
voice on that issue and if those of you
who are who were doing detailed research
on it take a look at a seminar and
symposium that took place at george
mason university in october two thousand
eight a lot of good stuff came out of
that so the reason i say plan colombia
is a success i sort of alluded to
navarre marks is a counterinsurgency
effort not as a counter narcotics effort
counter-narcotics at best and in
colombia even if when the numbers went
down they pushed it to other places
overall coca production has not really
gone down what it did do was enable a
Colombian state that as John sort of
suggested had some will but some lacking
in ability to do things that wanted to
do like fight back against Park that's
really where the success has come is
enabling a state that was looking a
little shaky for a while to push the
fart back to increasing marginalization
and it did that by providing helicopters
and training and all kinds of stuff so
that's why I suggest it was not so great
as a counter narcotics effort but
counter-narcotics was a way to make
counterinsurgency aid happen I mean
certainly prior to to the Iraq war
counterinsurgency was still kind of a
loaded term in the United States maybe
it still is depending on you
but the point is it was tough to sell us
counterinsurgency support to Colombia
that was pretty easy to sell
counter-narcotics support now the FARC
made it easy for those selling it this
way by being involved in the drug trade
but that's why I think Plan Colombia
could be coated a success I mean as you
saw by me keeping my hand up I think the
war on drugs is completely ridiculous
it's it's going to be a failure as long
as there's demand in the United States I
mean we have we have you know you
mentioned economics basic economics when
the demand a signal is this strong it's
going to be provided from somewhere and
whether it's meth labs in Western North
Carolina where I go see my mom and like
it's like oh another lab blew up or
whether it's the it's the jungles in
Colombia it's going to be an issue and a
lot of that just because of geography is
de sort of suggested is going to flow
through Mexico and it's going to be a
big issue there so it's it's not that I
think Plan Colombia you know solve the
drug problem I think it did help solve
the fog problem my name is ben schwartz
i'm also a super student the Office of
the President of Mexico recently Luisa
database of the violence in Mexico that
showed the rise that everyone was sort
of expecting and they blamed a lot of
that on exports of arms from the US but
they didn't I didn't see any numbers of
an increase of exports of alarms and
there was recently that arrest in
Arizona of law enforcement I believe
that was exporting arms I was wondering
if you could speak on if there's been an
increase in export of arms and what role
us arms have in the capacity of criminal
organization well I heard this third
hand but you know strategically Mexico's
bet on the top five as a matter of
national security with the Ron Rock
afghan-pakistan and from folks that I
respect
very well say that exactly what you're
saying is at least equally problematic
as drugs flowing north his arms flowing
south and on the ground you know again
my perspective is talking to cab drivers
in Mexico City and Monterey and aqua
pouco they're saying that these
factories they used to make legitimate
products are now storing these arms that
came from the north so I think your
point is a very good one as far as what
are we seeing for accurate and actual
numbers I have no idea where to begin I
couldn't I couldn't even hazard a guess
and I think that's probably the most
realistic story since they didn't
disclose it and they don't know on the
border anecdotally the flow started to
go down actually the more it became
public and there was there was bigger
guns for drugs trade from you know up
through say 2008-2009 and then once the
problem became more more publicly
addressed by by the US government
there's there's been the flow is
decreased slightly again but this is all
this is border anecdotes I can't I can't
give real hard numbers I'm skeptical
that it's that it's a that it's as
serious a problem on the ground as it is
politically i think that there's just as
many there's just as much flow from from
other sources as there is from the
united states yeah and to pick up on on
days point as i suggested with with
drugs being a demand-side problem i
think arms are demand side problem as
long as there's a demand and a boatload
of cash in Mexico they will get weapons
if the weapons come from the United
States right now it's because it's easy
if that gets hard there's there's plenty
of weapons roots coming from the south
through Columbia or Venezuela right it
can they can come by sea from you know
any of the vast stores of arms that are
sitting overseas I mean people in
Afghanistan don't have trouble getting
weapons and if you can get it in
Afghanistan you can get it to Karachi
and if you can get it to Karachi it's on
a boat
can go wherever so as long as there's
demand and money this will be a problem
we could we could you know build the
mythical you know Minutemen border wall
or force field and it's still going to
be a problem it for that simple reason
my name is Priya Sathya I'm a super
student my question is sort of on the
economic perspective results that's
influencing the security industry in
both the US and Mexico in terms of your
clients the control risk clients and
also the economic industries in Monterey
how much is their contracting US
businesses for security consulting's for
contracting for defense equipment
security equipment surveillance
equipment this sort of industry that is
sort of popping up as a result of the
violence and security situation in
Mexico if you could talk about bit about
that yeah now like before you walk away
Priya I guess my question is you want to
know what the average company is
spending or what the need is well I've
been sort of what the need is so the
companies like Pemex is really and there
are a lot of the huge industries in
Monterey they're the ones contracting
because they're getting targets of
kidnapping and extraordinary wrote
industry is building up their sort of
equipment and stuff yeah sure so we
don't do anything with with guns so
we're not a security consultancy that's
going to provide you with folks that can
that are physically armed and can
protect your employees I'll save for
John they're not they're not z or black
water or saris thank you so what we're
seeing primarily is how do you develop
the infrastructure at your plan here's
an anecdote back in almost a year ago so
last May there was there was this
operation that you know had a couple
hundred employees working 30 or 40
militants show up with ak-47s RPGs and
heads and other body parts and it was
show of force hey get out of here we
want we want to take your infrastructure
we want to take your building and we
want to use it for us
the employees all fled you know
naturally so so what are they doing now
it's trying to make that target harder
so it's reducing your exposure so
instead of flying you know the flag
saying this is who we are there you know
they want to go to an environment where
they don't necessarily know what they're
making in there and they're not the
hardest target the other stuff that
we're seeing executive protection tasks
so you know vice president from Houston
San Diego Minneapolis comes into town he
wants to know who's going to pick him up
at the airport what's his itinerary
going to be when's he going to get out
and he wants to make sure that it's done
safely other stuff where we're really my
focus is is helping organizations put a
process in place so developing a crisis
management structure because they don't
know what's going to happen so you know
the problem that that their friends had
to deal with last week is not the
problem they're going to deal with
tomorrow it's going to be something
different you know some kind of
permutation of what they had to be lit
so developing some kind of flexible
structure to put in place so they can
respond to almost anything and they have
a plan if it hits the fan what are they
going to do because they're not going to
stop operating there there's too much
financial incentive to continue to
operate in Mexico did that answer your
question or and again I can't begin to
guess no that's sort of that not so much
as in personal security but also the
equipment the sort of industry that's
popping up that like these major
companies in Mexico and also their
industries are looking to protect
themselves because the economic results
of this sort of I think it's more an
educational thing than a physical
preparedness it's not to say that
they're not doing the infrastructure
stuff but I think they're probably
putting more money into educating their
employees just one caveat on that the
Monterey Chamber of Commerce has
officially they've recommended that
businesses double the percentage of
operating costs budget that they're
spending on own security infrastructure
and security issues did they that's a
nurse quite so did they have a number to
start with like was average
percentage it was it average one percent
and they've taken it to three percent oh
okay which is smaller than I had
expected yeah but still tripling yeah hi
I'm mom I'm Vanessa anointment I'm an
associate of the university seminar in
Latin America here at ciba I'm also
Venezuela and I lecture and write a lot
about Latin American politics and Chavez
who is a bit of a thorn in my side but
anyway um as I said I'm Venezuela and I
was on the phone with my brother in
Caracas last night who was telling me
about the virtual kidnappings like you
don't understand now it's not the
problem is not as chaves I think we care
less about Travis than we do about crime
and violence it's so unbearable I don't
go out out of my house past 8pm you know
he's young he's you know and and he he
was saying and I know as of a few years
ago since Chavez has been in power with
about eight times more kidnappings three
times more likely to be murdered I think
those numbers have now said you know
just from one he took power to now I
have my own theories about the link
between violence and the erosion of
institutional independence and
governance that's me what do you think
do you have any views about because you
were talking about a blonde Colombia and
what you didn't mention plant Patriota
but also you know the sort of knock on
to the counterinsurgency that you in
Colombia you had a good political
structure and the well so that signals
to me that you do view a link as between
violence in these countries and the
political structure I'd want to hear
your views on it so I mean specifically
for kidnapping where governance fails
the business model is going to be
beneficial until they start prosecuting
the people that are perpetrating these
these kidnappings I don't see any end in
sight for Venezuela specifically we're
not seeing that and I mean I don't know
what your thoughts are but folks on the
ground when I speak to them they do
think that law enforcement is complicit
in not only express kaname
the kidnap for ransom I will say from my
own personal experience I think
Venezuela is a tremendous country and it
just it my heart aches when I go there
it's the only city i've been into in the
world Caracas is where I don't feel
comfortable going out at night and it's
just that you know that that sense that
you get and it also helps when a local
say oh yeah I know someone that's been
kidnapped sins yeah it's going to happen
and you know parents are legitimately
concerned when they're 19 20 23 year old
sons and daughters are going to go out
to a nightclub and they're going to get
picked up on their way home so I think
it's absolutely tragic but the sense
that I'm getting from this perspective
on the ground is I think the general
consensus is folks are skeptical of of
any kind of police force that's going to
combat you know particularly the
kidnapping problem in Caracas or
Maracaibo or Venezuela large and I think
many probably think that they are
complicit okay do you think that that do
you think that is that in any way tied
to who's president I mean now point
about institutions absolutely I mean I
sort of alluded to this earlier much of
the problem with violence whether it be
at least in my perception in Latin
America or in Iraq and Afghanistan is an
issue of political dynamics it's not
necessarily a shortage of trigger
pullers and so what you've seen my
perception are not a Latin American is
by by training but my perception is the
Chavez regime has systematically
hollowed out both Venezuelan state and
society in you know to my mind it looks
like not quite as extreme but a similar
dynamic to what Saddam Hussein did in
Iraq over the course of the 1980s and
1990s and you end up with an overweening
state that is nonetheless not terribly
effective and I think that's exactly
what you're seeing in Venezuela because
it's too much of a cult of personality
or what no not so much your whole
personality it's it's because it's
because loyalty is paramount loyalty not
only to a specific leader but to the
state apparatus and you know in in every
case where you see loyalty prized over
competence
the organization or indeed the entire
state but becomes a hollow shell at best
and you know you can point to example
after example be it South Vietnam in the
1970s where despite loads of aid I mean
absolutely the most military aid we've
given any country in the world you
couldn't produce an effective army why
because South Vietnamese people won't
fight no it's because this is the state
that it was based on was was this
loyalty promoting you know semi
kleptocracy and I think anywhere you see
those conditions like oh by the way
Afghanistan now you're going to have a
hard row to hoe in terms of providing
security and it doesn't have to be a
full-blown insurgency it clearly isn't
yet in in Venezuela or Mexico but it
still creates an environment where with
the lack of institutions be it courts be
it public service be it police it
creates this environment where where
lawlessness is going to about well
exactly i mean we have the death rates
of a country in a civil war absolutely i
mean i'm saying that's right i mean
worse they met worse than some I mean
some of the numbers I've seen suggest
that you're more likely to be killed in
Caracas than you are in Kabul right yeah
that's a country well more than Baghdad
certainly yeah thank you I felt safer in
Ramadi in 2007 than i did in Ciudad
Juarez in 2009 to your point about the
politics yeah yeah okay thank you and I
by the way I thought that your point
about loyalty over competence was a was
a very good one thank you for that thank
you and though out to be fair in in
Ramadi in 2007 you did have the full
weight of the US Marine Corps back in
your life
I feel pretty warm and fuzzy when I have
that too no matter where I am see two
other before we get on to the next
question just what concerns me and it's
not an answer it's more a question and I
want to know your senses we have it
seems to me just based on Venezuelans
that I know that because of the
political system many of them are
leaving it seems like the country's
getting robbed of its intellectual Lee
that are opting to come to the states
they're going to Miami or New York or
Bogota so I wonder from your perspective
as an academic that studies this if you
if this is a valid point and then to
what I'm seeing and this is more just a
point I'm seeing hesitancy from
multinational organizations to operate
in Venezuela they're getting to the
point where they're so I mean they're
building expropriation plants so what do
I do hopefully to prevent getting
expropriated but if I do what's my
reaction and they're they're spending a
lot of money to develop these plants so
they're getting point where they're
saying I don't want to I don't want to
I'm not gonna operate in Venezuela
rather than go to Venezuela I'm going to
go to Colombia or I'm going to go to
Brazil and I think i can do business
better there from an academic standpoint
my question to you is are either those
valid yes they are yes they are valid
points in fact the other conversation I
was having with my brother was about
immigration about possibly leaving the
contingency plans to leave Venice wha he
loves run as well very much lives there
doesn't want to leave it's far more
Venezuela it has been more of his life
there than I have but he says well you
know we need to have an exit strategy
and so I'm helping him with that part of
the problem is why people are leaving is
because also a lot of my friends have
been almost everybody I know has either
been kidnapped or shot many of my
friends have either been thrown in in
prison for speaking out against the
government or had their property seized
and it's rampant it's growing more and
more I mean I know dozens of people so
there is a sense of sort of legal
nihilism we're basically the state
basically operates at
at the will of what you say loyalty that
if you loyal to the regime to the
apparatus that then you're okay but if
not then or you know you're persecuted
and as I said I know many people close
people who have been persecuted so I so
that's one that that is one aspect but
there's also a sense in Venezuela and I
know in my mind also that the two are
not disconnected that the sense of that
like they're coming to get you also
somehow has also created the environment
for this lawlessness where it's either
the government might come and get you or
you're just going to be you know shot in
restaurants you know and that by just
some guy on the street but what I'm
trying to do is to sort of connect the
dots and that it was wondering how you
guys the practitioners saw that and yes
in terms of expropriations yeah they're
growing and almost I think something
like I was just getting I just got the
numbers by email something like eighty
percent of the expropriation of North
are now failed I used to try and promote
business i'm going to swell that when i
worked at their embassy in washington DC
many lifetimes ago and i couldn't seem
doing that job now you know I i really
don't know why you would invest him
going to swell unless you can sort of
afford to lose that money it's like that
portion of your portfolio that you just
give tomatoes thank you thank you I Brad
jenison a senior at undergrad my
question is from the security see my
guess would be directed at John what
level is there a baseline level security
in which people are not getting
kidnapped and I know that's going to be
relative to your status position and you
know how much you make but our guys
running three-car motorcades through
Mexico City still at risk of getting
kidnapped or if you're making less than
that and you've got one driver are you
mitigating some of that risk I'll say
it's mostly opportunistic so the vast
majority what we're seeing it's a lot of
times it's user error so it's 2 a.m.
and they're pulling out their their bank
card and they're standing outside an ATM
and they're pulling a bunch of money out
and then they're getting nabbed you know
and they've been drinking for the last
six or seven hours we're seeing much of
that you know executive types are
driving you know they're hiring four
five six individuals to protect them and
dry them in a motorcade but but there's
this really interesting dynamic that I
think you see when you're in DF and you
see the 16 and 17 year old kids they you
know they look like babies and they're
driving in their Ferraris I mean I think
what's really interesting and DF is
there there's so much money in that city
and folks it's almost like they just
whistle past the graveyard like oh it
can't happen to me so I guess my answer
is it's mostly opportunistic the folks
that are proactive are not generally
getting picked up doesn't mean that it's
not ever happen but I'll say most of the
time that let's answer I'm chicken with
and this incident here I have two
questions here one is what is the just
now you mentioned the institutional new
Georgian so what is the root cause for
the for such an institution for the
usual in of the institutions and the
second one is it seems to me that in the
past 20 years maybe the Violence Unit
American has accelerated but can you
give us a comparison about what about
maybe before nineteen ninety before
because we know after before that time
the economic and Latin America actually
experience the economic in miracles and
then at that time economic situation was
very well was good and but after that
and then the economic situation
deteriorated so do you contribute the
increasing imbalance in Latin America to
the deterioration of economic situations
in these countries well particularly
Mexico thank you I wouldn't I wouldn't
attribute it to the continuing violence
in mexico i would i would say it's
cyclical in the sense that to the
earlier points about Venezuela the
political institutions throughout Mexico
are and the security institutions
throughout Mexico are not capable of and
have not maintained the growth that the
economic institutions did in a fairly
short period of time and and I think
unfortunately all the trends continue
downward when we're talking about how
quickly those institutions are going to
catch up does that answer your question
or is it I think I have a couple of
thoughts on root causes I think it
varies from place to place in Venezuela
most it I mean I'll sound like a Chavez
basher but that's fine i think it's
pretty early time interesting in mexico
vs mexico i think i think Mexico has
always been a fairly weak state
relatively speaking I mean you know now
I'm going to get into pure speculation
but you know the United States was a
weak state for a long time and we went
through a variety of experiences that
built up state power you know we had the
Articles of Confederation they became
the Constitution because of some
uprisings amongst other things we then
had a civil war which greatly
accelerated the growth of state power we
had a depression we had World War two we
had all of these things that were solved
in a way by the by the growth of state
capacity now some people including my
own libertarian self boom own this a
little bit but it did produce a pretty
effective state now we may be seeing
problems with it now in terms of the
Democratic consensus breaking down but
nonetheless you saw this progression
Mexico to my mind and again I'm I'm not
a Latin American us so if you think I'm
foolish I'd please raise your hand I'm
sorry we're recording those sessions but
nonetheless you know the Mexican state
despite despite in on paper being quite
powerful i think in practice has been
relatively weak you know it went through
a series of sort of
spurts of growth at various times and
Pemex paradoxically I think actually
contributed to this because when you
have oil money you can be a bit of a run
to a state right you don't have to build
up your extractive capacity and you see
a lot of flabbiness in these kind of
states norway in the UK or sort of
exceptions in part because they had pre
robust states before they found a while
so that's your off the off the shoot
from the hip hypothesis on online Mexico
and then so you have this relatively
weak state that then encounters a
massive influx of illegal money right
and so it's it's you know it's a it's a
well the analogy I want to use would be
in politic given the recent events in
Japan but it's a it's a big flood of
money into an area that's not very well
prepared for it I think that's really
the story of Mexico again I think the
dynamic is different from from country
to country you know in terms of the of
the economics bit I think you know it is
a little bit of a misperception to say
that that overall violence has gone up
in Latin America the character of the
violence has changed the places it takes
place has changed Mexico being the
singular example but Latin America was
pre violent placed before nineteen
ninety as well you had a raging Civil
War I mean Colombia's probably as Dave
pointed out or and John both it's
probably gotten a little better in the
past few years El Salvador was in the
middle of a horrible civil war and
violence levels in that country are only
now starting to get back up to that
level Guatemala had decades of
absolutely murderous near genocide all
civil war so I think what you've seen is
a change in the in the character of the
violence and where it takes place more
than you know you could maybe look at
absolute levels and figure it out but I
think it's a little misperception to say
before nineteen ninety all good in Latin
America after nineteen ninety not but
clearly I think they're links to
economic growth that have changed the
character but it's hard to tear out
tease out which is which you know in
Chile you've seen economic growth but
did it lead to the reduction in
in violence there or was it because the
nature of the state changed I think it's
the it's the latter and these things
were a bit disconnected I'm rambling
thank you hi I'm dr. Palmer and I'm
president of cinema verite international
inc my question basically is related to
connecting dots of violence that has and
I'm you may not have an answer for this
but there has been talk that Qaddafi if
he please may go to Venezuela and that
Siobhan Chavez would open the door to
him of course if wherever he goes he
would bring millions with him do you see
any likelihood for that you have any
information on that and again thank you
I don't think we have anything on that
specifically certainly it seems
plausible given it the relationship that
the guys have but you know I don't I
don't have any additional information on
them no I don't have any either no it's
certainly possible i mean dictators have
to find someplace to go and it just
depends on who their friends are so Idi
Amin billions with them it would be
consistent with Chavez track right yeah
I think but but it like that's why I say
plausible but I think I couldn't say
okay thank you thank you okay I actually
have a couple of questions and if you
think of more we've got probably 10
minutes less but but but to that I was
interested in that I'm a little
surprised didn't come up one is what do
you see the potential for flow of some
of these trends up into the United
States crossing in from Mexico into it
to at least you know you may be beyond
the immediate border but into the
broader those four states you mentioned
the border the border mexico in the
second you know one of the reasons i
wanted you guys here is you do have an
Iraq Afghanistan perspective that I
think a lot of people that work in Latin
America don't have and so maybe you
could have any thoughts on similarities
differences anything you see that
carries over from the two um well I'll
address the first question I'm going to
let him tackle the problem north but we
have seen a flow south so what we've
seen in the first where is it almost
April now
going back to the fall is we've seen the
Zetas as a new alliance joined in Mexico
we've seen the Zetas start to operate in
Guatemala I really don't know about any
kind of flow northbound but we have seen
that most of the texas-mexico border is
privately owned land most of the border
of west of el paso is public land El
Paso statistically is the third safest
city in the United States and obviously
Ciudad Juarez is if not the murder
capital of the world at least one of the
top it's competing with Caracas as the
murder murder central for the Western
Hemisphere I think the trending is that
Arizona has been a problem since those
of you who studied the us-mexico border
or us-mexico relations in detail or
raise your hand if you've heard of
operation gatekeeper in anybody in
California that began to move the flows
of illegal immigration in illegal
trafficking into into Arizona the
trafficking north through Arizona is
strong enough that in many of the
national forests where where the United
States has just placed signs that say
warning smuggling taking place here and
and does not have the capacity or the
infrastructure to maintain a regular
Border Patrol presence Smuggler's are
actually able to set up patrol bases and
they've been able to do this for the
past decade where they can set up a
patrol base flowing north and then you
know set it up move cargo pull it back
and and they've been a they started
doing that in the mid to late 90s and
because they've been consistently
successful with it that's I think going
to be you know and again most of this is
outside of public view but it is one of
the reasons why Arizona as a state has
had many of the political issues that
they've had because
ranchers see this on a day-to-day basis
and or if not on a daily basis on a
consistent enough basis that that nobody
in Arizona who lives within 70 or 80
kilometres of the us-mexico border
doesn't have a dog and usually a weapon
so you don't want to touch the Iraq
Afghanistan either one of you um I'll
I'll tackle it latin america in my
experience is not a war zone when i went
to iraq and flew into Baghdad
International it was occupied by Allied
forces that's not the case when I flying
to Mexico City or Caracas or Rio de
Janeiro or sao paulo or Buenos Aires and
until it's there I think the best thing
to tell people is try to mitigate the
risk but you can certainly operate in
Latin America the lawlessness of Latin
America though is is troubling and I
think I've so most of my time and we can
talk we're running short but I spent a
lot of time traveling alone I was placed
under surveillance twice and I can talk
about the details of that at different
points generally one of the times I I
was on my way across the us-mexico
border so it wasn't as big of a deal the
other time it was enduring for a couple
of days and I ended up changing clothes
once I realized what the problem was to
make a long story short I was believed
to be a min and I hit man a Mennonite
hit man well there was a wait a minute
Mennonite hit me a min and I hit min so
you drove like a black car and no no I
travel generally in by bus in in Latin
America that's been in my experience the
the easiest way to maintain a low
profile unfortunately again to make a
very long story short I was in a city
called quantum oak in western Chihuahua
that's right off of there's a train that
runs from Los Mochis up to Chihuahua
city it's through an area called the bar
on Casa del cobre which is the Copper
Canyon it's beautiful it's the largest
canyon in North America it's even
not it's even slightly larger than the
Grand Canyon but there's a there's a a
rivalry there as I as I learned between
the Tarahumara Indians and the minute
there's a group of Old Colony Mennonites
that live in and around the city of
quality milk which is about two hours
west of the capital of Chihuahua city
both groups are involved in drugs let's
just say I looked a lot like a minute
night when I was going through the
Tarahumara Indian area and they weren't
too happy about me being there I had
people watching me for a couple of days
took me a while to figure this out once
i got to call Tim oak I realized that
not all the Mennonites were we're doing
the Lord's work and I changed into jeans
and a Yankees cap and I was good oh my
sorry to take a gun day yesterday you
have to be quick to ya the Central
America quick anecdote a couple of weeks
ago I was flying back from San Francisco
to JFK and I my cellular which was
stolen at the san francisco airport body
by the cargo handlers and I I was able
to to discover that they were able to
make it some telephone calls to to
Honduras that doesn't necessarily mean
that the guys that there is a honduras a
catrachos mafia and the san francisco
airport but a it made my point is are
there international links between the
DVD with the US gangs la gangs in
particular between the dimaras in
honduras and in salvador and i don't
know how they call them in Guatemala but
basically the same notion of banks that
have our increment actually I on a
related question bless to what extent
the the problem of crime in Central
America was come
founded by the informal so to speak
expulsion of of gang members from
salvador in particular in the in the
late 90s to your first question a big
connection between prison gangs
particularly la ma the Mexican Mafia and
and on you and the very modest thanks
yeah and I think the same thing I mean
again I live in Washington DC so that
that's where my knowledge comes from but
folks that's it they have links back to
the modest and Salvador and Honduras so
I don't think that you're wrong but I
can't say without a shadow of a doubt
that i have any kind of proof that
you're right there's there's I'll be a
little more definitive at least on
Salvador again just because I've been
there a good bit lately it's a pretty
clear link and in fact there's a
hierarchy and in an interesting sort of
turnabout of how the Mafia the Sicilian
Mafia worked the Mara's in the united
states are actually higher status than
Morris in Salvador so if you go from
being Amara in sin Salvador to Amara in
LA even if you were a lieutenant in
Salvador you're demoted to basically you
know back to 22 Street sort of tough if
you go from the US down to Salvador
you're automatically a lieutenant even
if you were just like you know a pipe
hitter on the street so there is a link
and that in the hierarchy is a bit
inverse of how it normally worked and
that's because the Mara's grew up in the
states right so the states are actually
more the home to the Morris then
Salvador so to your second point yeah
the the time to go home boys thing in
the 1990s I mean there weren't really
Morris to speak of i mean there was
violence but it was not Maura activity
in the same way until Mara's from the
United States went back to Salvador so i
can't speak to towada mala or any other
places like that but definitely with
Salvador there are links and the u.s.
branches are that are the senior
branches
last question thick part of my question
but real quick too piggybacking on the
moderate situation but we talked about
geography in Mexico how much do the
trains have anything to do with the
violence and the migration that goes
through Mexico coming up from Central
America and you know we talked about
proximity to the US just the migration
effect and immigration through Mexico
into the United States how much is that
affecting the violence and then also
specifically with what amala because I
know a little bit more about what the
mala but just in general like monodon or
salvador don't do to us but in what the
mod specifically the private security
firms that have started to come up that
are better armed and the police forces
you know we have these you know try to
support them from the United States
protective to build up their their
police force how can we deal with these
private security firms that are already
there and people have already bought
into and how does that lend itself to
like you said you know the violence in
in in Central America now is not that
bad it does on a war zone but at the
same time everyone seems to have their
own little army so maybe that's why it's
not it doesn't seem like war even though
it kind of is all three gate great
questions I think we could probably do a
conference or seminar in each of them
all right I'll invite you but but but to
your to your first one as far as the
trains in just an interesting anecdote
about it the train system in the Train
infrastructure in Mexico used to be much
more robust than it currently is post
NAFTA in the 90s for a number of reasons
the Mexican government determined that
they that it was more profitable to to
invest heavily in busing infrastructure
and Mexico actually has one of the most
robust bus systems and in national bus
systems in in Latin America I do think
certainly the anecdotes that you have
for Guatemala in terms of the flow is
coming up in the train yes it is an
issue just to touch on the private
security thing it is an issue I don't
really have a good answer but certainly
again I keep going back to Salvador just
because I've been there yeah you can't
go anywhere really to speak up without
there being unarmed
at least nearby the only other place
that's not an active war zone I've been
where you see that was in was in
Pakistan in Islamabad where yeah even
the furniture store had a guy with the
shotgun out front so since and
salvador's not quite to that level and I
guess I should be clear when I say that
i am talking son Salvador if you go even
a little bit outside of the capital
things get a lot better for sort of
weird reasons and one of the interesting
things about Salvador is that the areas
that were insurgent held during the
1980s tend to be the safest bits in
terms of crime and so again you could
probably have a whole conference on the
dynamics that led to that but in sin
Salvador yeah there's a lot of private
security every self-respecting condo
complex has some kind of patrol that
comes by frequently it's what people do
in response to to these kind of
situations if there's if there's state
failure something will fill that vacuum
and if it's not crime which a lot of it
is I mean every pupuseria is paying
tribute to the Mara's I mean it's not
it's not a joke I mean you can see
little old ladies making their dough and
sometime that day somebody will come by
and get paid off but the other response
is okay the state has failed me I don't
want to be victimized by criminals you
know I'll go with option see if I can
and and that's what you've seen I think
in sin Salvador and we'll probably see
in other parts of the of latin america
mexico i think is a little different
because you know as I said it's it's
weird because you have a state that is
on paper pretty strong and so will
probably be pretty resistant to you know
massive numbers of armed contractors but
at the same time the state isn't willing
to provide security in the same way
either so you get these weird dynamics
where you know you have a state that
will push back against alternative
centers of power but isn't able to
actually do its job it's kind of a
suspect Venezuela will be the same way
so at least in Salvador you have that
private option in a way that you don't
in other places I don't know what you
guys think
nobody's going to fight me all right
well the last thing to do that is to
thank our panelists thank you so much
for attending so